Oh convention I mean the RNC delegates
here are about to nominate
and even though the 480 fourth top
female golfer in the world is here there
are many other important Republicans who
are not Jeb Bush pulls Georgia's Marco
Rubio Mitt Romney not even John McCain
is here
apparently he's hiking in the Grand
Canyon not even the governor of Ohio
John Kasich this year cuz he had a thing
with his wife's nephews baptism but
there are many here who don't have such
handy excuses delegates who are bound to
vote for dongju observer and now they're
coming out of the shadows and spitting
out the kool-aid Donald Trump is a
racist he's a misogynist he is an
authoritarian he's a nationalist he is a
neo-fascist Donald Trump is a one-man
constitutional crisis literally how
displeased are you with your party's
nominee on a scale of just missed to
vomiting in your mouth one being barely
moved to 10:00 vomiting yeah 225 point
seven so the vomits all over it's like
my guts are on the floor I basically
exploded do you think the Republican
Party is going the way of the polar bear
or is that too much climate science is
the polar bear become hearsay I got up
on this I'm sorry it's okay you're
conservative it's fine climate change
climate change or what would you do to
stop Trump like would you turn your home
into a Pokemon go Jim I've done
everything that I could do at this top
dog have you done that though it's a
challenging time for the Republican
Party
right I don't know where we go from here
Donald Trump is so far removed from what
I think the average conservative
cesspool it's not the present in a room
full of Trump supporters voices of
dissent are silenced I wanted to make
sure my new friends were okay blink
twice if you're safe I think what a
snake we're safe I think we're safe I
think I think the police officers in the
Sicari do this in place has protected us
from people outside but it's a people
inside the party that they're the most
dangerous that's what I mean I'm an
inside
I do feel let down by the fact that
there are other Republicans who seem to
think that Donald Trump is an acceptable
nominee those are the people I've been
let down by I wouldn't be surprised if
he's just hypnotized a large percentage
of the Republican population but don't
you think that like Trump is the the
spore that grew off of the moldy gym
socks of the GOP because he I think he's
a demagogue but but like for word
Republicans already headed down
demagoguery Donald Trump is not talking
policy nothing he said is substantive
that comes from anything that's derived
in a deep sense of moral conviction or
philosophy both delegates admit they
can't do much to stop Trump now but both
say they think is chances of winning in
the general are slip okay so what's your
next move 2016 comes and goes Clinton's
president where do you gotten back at it
again man I'll be here in four years and
we'll get together in four years and
we'll talk about how we stop the dollars
our presidency there's a nice idea but